Could you please discuss freewill and Sam Harris's and others' ideas of its
non-existence?
Well,
that's a good complicated question to kick things off.
So I want to tell you a little bit about how to conceptualize freewill.
I think first because it's obvious that we don't have infinite free will are our
choice.
Our choices are constrained in all sorts of ways.
And I think part of the reason that there's a,
a continual discussion about freewill and the philosophical and the
philosophical literature is because
just conceptualizing the issue properly is extraordinarily difficult.
So I like to think about it,
at least in part,
the way that you think about a game.
You know,
if you're playing a game,
obviously the game has rules.
So if it's a chess game or a basketball game,
then there are things that you can do in and things that you can't do.
And but,
and so it's,
it's a,
it's a closed world in some sense.
But the fact that there are things you can't do when you play a game also seemed
to open up a universe of possibilities for things that you can do.
So chess obviously constraints you to a board and to a certain number of men and
to a certain pattern of rules.
But the strange thing is,
is that when you put in those rules,
because rules sound like limits,
they sound always like things you can't do.
But when you set up a constrained world like that and you lay out a system of
rules,
what you do is open up an infinity of,
of a near infinity of possibilities.
Same with music.
You know,
music has rules obviously,
and,
and if you follow the rules,
then you can make an infinite variety of music.
And so,
and so there's a,
there's a very interesting dynamic that's hard to understand between constraint
and possibility.
And there's a deep idea that's associated with that that I read in some Jewish
commentary on,
on the biblical stories that I,
I read a long time ago.
I'm talking about the relationship between God and man.
And the idea was that God,
imagine,
uh,
being with the classical attributes of God,
omniscience,
omnipotence and omnipresence,
all seeing,
all knowing and all powerful.
What is it being like that lack,
and obviously the answer is nothing,
right?
Because by definition those three traits provide for absence of limitation.
But then that's exactly what's lacking is limitation.
And there's some strange connection between limitation.
And I was saying say limitation that that's rule governed as I mentioned before,
and the opening up of possibility.
So it isn't necessarily the case that now determine determinism and limitation
aren't exactly the same thing,
but they're analogous than they need to be discussed together.
Okay,
so now,
so that's the first thing is that our,
whatever our free choice is,
it isn't limited.
It's limited,
it's deeply limited.
Now here's another thing.
If I take my arm and I go like this,
see,
I'll do that again.
Now you see there's a movement like that and then my hands stopped just before
my,
my other hand.
Now it takes a certain amount of time for the neural messages to go from my
brain to my arm and back and the time it takes my hand to go like this and stop
is actually shorter than the time it takes a message to get to my brain.
And back.
So what that means is that when I,
when I planned this movement,
which is called a ballistic movement,
it's called a ballistic movement because it's like a bullet.
Once you let it go,
it's gone.
There's no calling back.
I've actually organized the neurological and muscular sequences that enable that
action before it's implemented.
I set all that up and then it's released and the whole thing cascades.
And so once the action has been released,
let's say,
then I don't really have any free will because I can't stop it now.
So,
so you think about that,
it looks like there's a temporal gradient with regards to freewill.
Is that as you look out into the future meet perhaps the farther out you look
into the future?
Um,
the farther down the road,
let's say,
the more free your choices are,
but the closer they get to implementation,
the more they become deterministic governed by standard cause a processes.
And there's some transition point where they change from being what we would
describe as choice that we haven't got to free choice yet,
but at least to choice.
There's some transition point between now and ballistic movement.
Here's another way of thinking about it.
Like we know for example,
that people who are expert at playing the piano look ahead of where they're
playing and,
and they're doing the same thing.
They're watching the notes,
they're seeing where they're going,
but and then their disinhibiting,
the automated structures that enabled them to play what they've practiced so
thoroughly.
They're disinhibited.
Those structures,
and then they go automatically and then what happens if you make a mistake is
that consciousness notes the error and then unpacks the motor sequences that
have been practiced and then you read,
practice them and sequenced them again until they become automatic and
deterministic.
So there's choice in that.
You're reading ahead,
but there's no choice in that.
Once you've read ahead and disinhibited the actions,
then they run ballistically and then you can think about the same thing that's
happening when you're driving in a car.
You don't look right in front of you when you're driving a car because whatever
is right in front of you,
if you're going 40 miles an hour,
whatever you've already run over,
you look a quarter of a mile down the road.
And that gives you the opportunity to see what's coming.
And to set up a sequence of increasingly automated movements that culminate in
whatever it is that you're doing while you're driving.
And so there's a gradation from choice to determinism,
a temporal gradation.
And,
and I,
I don't often see that addressed when people talk about will and now Sam's issue
with freewill is that if you get someone to do something like lift their finger
and you,
and you scan their brains using a variety of techniques while they're doing
that,
what you'll see is that there's an action potential that emerge and you ask them
to voluntarily move their fingers.
So they're doing it,
let's say by free choice,
there's an action potential that you can,
that you can read off the brain that occurs before the person either moves their
finger or let's say decides to move their finger.
And that occurs quite a bit before the feeling of volunteerism or that voluntary
act.
And so that's been read by Benjamin Libet who did the experiments,
um,
as indication that even the feeling of voluntary choices determined.
But I don't think that that's a very useful way of addressing the issue because
the issue of when you lift your finger up again is it requires pre-programming
to disinhibit.
Like you know how to do this right.
You don't have to learn to do that.
So you have a little automated circuit that does this sort of thing.
All these finger movements and everything,
you can see babies practicing them and they develop automated circuitry that
tends to be posterior left hemisphere in order to run those,
those automated processes out.
And what you're basically doing when you decide to do something that's a routine
that you've already practiced or,
or made out of sub routines that you've already practiced is disinhibiting them.
And the,
the degree to which you might regard that as free.
Exactly is unclear as are the temporal limitations.
So I don't think that Liberty's experiments demonstrate conclusively that
there's no such thing as free will,
even though there are action potentials that indicate that there is brain
activity signaling,
even the onset of a voluntary choice,
um,
voluntary choice early.
Now.
Um,
another thing that we might look at in relationship to that is,
um,
yeah,
so we can look at it phenomenologically and we could also look at it in,
in,
in relationship to how people treat one another.
So phenomenologically it seems clear that we have free choice and it isn't
obvious to me why we have consciousness if free choice isn't real because
consciousness looks to me like a mechanism that deals with potential before it's
transformed into actuality,
let's say.
And I think consciousness is also that the faculty,
so to speak,
or a manifestation of the faculty that enables us to preprogram deterministic
actions.
So again,
let's think about someone playing the piano.
They're practicing,
you know,
after you repeat and you repeat your,
your finger movements if you're playing the piano,
any complex motor skill is like that.
You have to repeat it and repeat it and repeat it and repeat it.
And you're using consciousness to program it,
to sequence the motor movements and to pay attention to them.
That all seems voluntary and it involves the activation of a tremendous amount
of your brain because if you're doing something new,
a lot of your brain is activated and then as you practice it,
the amount of brain that's activated decreases.
It shifts from right to left and then it shifts from frontal to posterior and a
smaller and smaller area.
So what's happening is that consciousness is creating little machines in the
back of your head that do things in an automated manner.
And
the the,
the volume that consciousness looks like consciousness appears and feels that
would be the phenomenal logical land as if it's doing that voluntarily and it is
associated with a different pattern of brain activity.
And so,
okay,
so there's that,
there's the long phenomenological reality of voluntary choice and effort as
well.
Cause conscious programming of that sort is also effortful.
It doesn't seem to run deterministically like a clock does.
And then finally,
there's also,
and I don't know what you think about this with regards to evidence,
but what constitutes evidence is not always that easy to determine even in in
the scientific domain.
So imagine,
think about how we think about ourselves and other people and how we treat
ourselves and other people.
You could imagine that you're like a clock running down and that's like a
deterministic model,
but people aren't,
clocks were dissipative structures.
A clock is something that runs downhill.
But human beings,
you can look up dissipative structure.
I think that was an idea that was first formulated by the physicist Schrodinger
we,
we're,
we're not,
we're not clocks by any stretch of the imagination.
And we take energy in and we disperse energy and,
and we were anti entropic in an in a temporary sense.
So that makes us,
and,
and so,
and life is as well shorting a wrote about that in a book called what is life?
And
yeah,
we don't what we seem to do,
this is how it looks to me.
We don't contend with the present and we're not driven by the past.
Instead,
what we see in front of us is a landscape of possibility.
And my wilder moments,
I think that's associated with the physical idea of multiple universes.
But that's in my wilder moments.
It's just a speculation.
And so what we see in front of us is,
uh,
an array of potential universes.
And those are the universes that we could bring about as a consequence of our
actions and it,
and we make choices to the right or the left.
There's a lot of mythological speculation about that sort of idea to in an
ethical sense,
cause we decide what sort of reality that we want to bring into being.
And so we encounter potential like God did at the beginning of time when he made
order out of chaos.
Chaos is this chaotic potential.
We confront chaotic potential with our consciousness and we cast that into
reality and that now then you think,
well,
is that really the case?
Well,
that's hard to say because there are limits to our knowledge about consciousness
and about reality.
But if you treat yourself like you're a free moral agent with choice and that
you can determine the course of your life,
then you seem to get along better with yourself and to be less anxious and to be
more productive.
And if you treat other people like that,
that they're free agents that are making voluntary choices about how reality is
going to come into being and you reward them when they do it properly and you
punish them,
uh,
or otherwise discipline them when they don't,
when they do it badly,
then your relationships with them seem to work.
And then if we predicate our society on the presupposition that each individual
human being is capable of doing just that,
then we seem to have extremely functional societies.
And so,
and this is something that Sam Harris has been taken to task for many times,
is if you dispense with the idea of free will,
how is it you organize your relationship to yourself,
your interactions with your family and your relationships with the broader
social community?
It's a very complicated issue.
So I believe strongly that we have freewill,
that we're responsible for our choices.
Those choices are constrained in many,
many ways.
I think there's a gradient of freewill from free out into the future to
increasingly constrained as the present manifest itself to deterministic in the
moment when,
when in the moment of action we,
and you might think that we entered the realm of deterministic causality at the
moment of action,
something like that.
That's how it looks to me.
So.
Well,
so at this rate,
we're going to answer about five questions so that,
but that was a very,
very hard one.
So anyways,
I hope that's helpful.